good evening everybody sure they can
start I think it's about 6:15 I'll start
by introducing myself good evening my
name is Danny Kendall I am the chairman
of planning committee a and I'll be
chairing tonight's meeting in accordance
with the rules and procedures set out in
the front page of your agendas before we
get started if I could just a few bits
of housekeeping if I could remind people
to make sure their mobile phones are set
to silent which I'm doing right now
that'll be fantastic as well it's never
nice to be caught out and also to let
members of the public know it's very
loud
members of the public know that this
meeting is being recorded and will be
available for you to watch re-watch at
your leisure on YouTube should you wish
to do so in the next day or two that
being said if I could just ask people at
the top table here to introduce
themselves please Olivia Quinn committee
services lost chambers legal services
Dale Barca planning manager Stuart
velocity planning officer Irene weather
stone planning officer rocky flying
officer thank you to clarify your role
here please yes thank you
I'm the planning manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision taking I'm bound by the Royal
Town Planning Institute code of
Professional Conduct and planning
committee members are not bound by an
advice from officers or by their
recommendations thank you Jeff it's
wonderful Thank You Dale right okay that
being done I think we can move to our
first item on the agenda all due to
absence please Henry sir if it is and
substituting for encounter Richard's
wonderful thank you and welcome
councilor thank you for doing this trout
disclosure of interests do we have any
disclosure of interests yes councillor
Barnes
the German army thank you any further
declarations now I've got one I received
an email for on item nine which I've got
to confess not all that came through so
I'm not had time to read all of that a
slide to email issue on that as well
counts the parent good evening chair I
also had an email regarding the occasion
for thirty-one college loan that's okay
everybody received that okay so we have
that though no other declarations of
interest lovely in that case the minutes
item three or over the meeting held on
the second block boba
you will content that I sign there's a
true record of meeting in which case we
can get to her first documentation so
that's about on page 13 of your agendas
and this is application reference 19
slash 0 what and 75 1 / ful and is for
orchard nurseries duck Lane
well that 11 the description of the
development that is the demolition of
existing nursery buildings and the
erection of Lyme dwellings and
associated works
Stewart party is that presenting officer
close to you Thank You chairman good
evening this proposal as the chair is
just elaborate on is seeking full
permission for the demolition of
existing nursery buildings and the
erection of nine Wellings
and also csworks this application site
is within the village of Welford a
Nathan as displayed by this black dots
on the plan here we see the application
boundary outlined in red one can see two
separate public rights-of-way one in the
dotted green indicator but I thought the
Green Line one in to the north of the
application site and one just to this
south of the application site both of
them entirely outside the red line
boundary as you can see part of the
application sites as you can see
indicated by this purple line here is
in a conservation area specifically a
small segment of the existing access
trap the entire the rest of the
application sites including all of the
built form proposed is entirely outside
of the conservation area here we have a
satellite aerial view of the application
site to give you a bit more of a flavor
as to where we are amongst other
features you can see the river even
flowing to the north and north east here
we have the existing site plan Ursa
missus detailing the site and its
current guys and indeed the cemetery
location plan in the top right corner
highlighted here here we now see the
proposed site layout plan and before you
this evening one can also see here the
black dotted lines indicating the
existing site layout the site features
of the currently on site Steve it's and
context as what's being proposed here we
have a proposed street scene plan
showing the front elevations of most of
the dwellings one can see of the variety
and the design aesthetic proposed in a
very in addition to a different range in
bulk and height here we see the
elevations for plot seven and nine which
weren't included on the previous plan
you just saw here we have an indicative
floor plan layout of one of the
dwellings specifically plot two here we
now some photos of a site and its
surroundings here we're now stood on the
existing access road looking northwards
one can see the extent of the existing
commercial buildings and glass houses
that are currently on site here we have
stood in a similar position a little
further northwards at the access road
now looking eastwards towards another
commercial unit separately we can see
here in addition to an area identified
as meadow and then the mature trees here
which comprised the eastern boundary of
the site we have a further commercial
building clearly which is supposed to be
demolished we're now stood closer
towards duck lane looking eastwards
one can see the presence of some
domestic the cordon commercial
paraphernalia the nursery business and
the further building as I say to be
demolished the principle of the removal
of this nursery business and its
associated buildings and erection of
residential developments has already
been established by the panel
inspectorate's
this application through increasing the
already approved number of dwellings
from five to nine would still lead to a
vast reduction and the built form that
is currently on the site this proposed
has been assessed and found to be
acceptable in officers view and would
lead to a high quality low density
residential scheme on an area of
brownfield previously developed land
chairman the recommendations to grant
this application following the
completion of a section 106 agreement
for the reasons set out on pages 25 and
26 of your agendas thank you thank you
okay speaker on this one that capsule
Jaime Hockaday from wealthy parish
council please so you have three minutes
if you'd remain seated for any questions
at the end I'll give you a 15-second
warning towards the end of your time yes
that case Council over to you thank you
and I start like to start by reminding
councillors that there was a refusal for
this foreign application on this site in
November 2016
for five houses and the policy or toward
the policy objections at that point in
the refusal were the gap between Welford
and Westin which is policy 86 in the
neighbourhood plan and also this is this
site outside the built-up area boundary
so it's an open countryside site so that
decision by this council to refuse was
appealed and I'd like to recite just two
paragraphs from the appeal decision so
paragraph 59 I quote the proposed
dwellings would not project further east
than the existing three dwellings within
the site which would have a positive
effect in reducing the current spread of
development to the east so the proposal
before you this evening does project a
further east and therefore is contrary
to the inspectors decision st. paragraph
I quote the nature of the development on
the site would change the overall
effects would enhance the gap between
the settlements the proposal between you
tonight does not enhance the gap between
the settlements I continue
moreover the replacement of built form
with areas of substantial garden land
and the creation of a new wild meadow
area would represent landscape and
ecology benefits so the proposal before
you tonight is for nine houses that's
almost 100 percent increase from the
five and as a result of that the density
is obviously greater and those
substantial Gardens were reduced by
approximately 50% and also one of those
houses is built on that part of that
ecological area and then I continue with
the inspector paragraph 16 the proposed
dwellings would not dominate the view in
the same way as the current mass of the
buildings in terms of the greenhouses
the existing greenhouses are four point
two six meters tall you've seen that on
the plan you've seen that actually the
hedges hide those greenhouses the nine
houses before you this evening have rich
heights up to nine point two meters and
chimneys up to eleven and a half meters
and I would suggest that is also
contrary
to the inspectors decision so for those
reasons I would ask you to refuse
tonight's application then principal
policy objections are the reduction in
the gap between Welford and Western AG
say 10 seconds and the open countries
the effect on the open countryside
policy 85 thank you very much any
questions from the committee Katz Lipari
good evening counselor I just wonder
whether you can advise when the last
housing needs survey was undertaken and
what the situation is on the housing
need in Welford okay we have a recently
adopted housing needs survey it's been
undertaken this year and it was adopted
approximately two months ago and this
application does not take that into
account at all any further questions
that case Council thank you very much
for your time thank you
we move now to annex speaker mr. Andrews
please
welcome mr. Anders so the sentence a few
as well you have three minutes we'd
remain seated for any questions yeah
thank you
I'm here to object but only on the
grounds of the plot nine which is as the
counselor highlighted is outside of the
original plan which was granted on the
appeal on the previous planning
application we live in the last house in
western on Haven and the welcomed the
opportunity of having a nice green belt
as an additional tree planting and in
the back of the green houses so as it
like I say the the only objection we've
got to the development is is the plot
nine house other than that we would
welcome the removal of the green houses
because as it stands at the moment six
o'clock in the morning we have Hyde G
V's reversing into the site forklift
beeping steel trolleys being rattled
around so it's quite noisy from our
point of view and now that winters come
or winter is here we have a constant hum
from the heating system in the place
which can be heard all night long so yes
we object to plot nine but we would like
to see the see the development just to
get rid of the greenhouses thank you
that's great thank you do you have any
questions counsel Jennings
the to the bottom right hand corner so
yes so we are down there just over the
brook the trees and hedgerows between
you there are some current trees there
and but one of them is in a dangerous
nexus just fallen down the lean and
against something else
so there's gonna be some serious
partying going on there so the now that
there's a gap in the trees we can
clearly see the green houses from our
house so and if if there's worked under
the trees they will become visible from
the house but on the on the original
plan the 2 2016 1 I think it was
highlighted that there was gonna be some
additional tree planting in that area ok
any further questions in that case thank
you very much your titles quite nice
monkey thank you so we went up to the
applicant sort of the applicants aims I
should say Jane Cashmore architect
Robert Evans
welcome hello right so YouTube between
you have a combination of six minutes
which of course previous two speakers
together
mr. Evans are you intending to take part
in this or is it mainly just you just
have questions questions no technical
questions yeah listen no case over to
you thank you good evening thank you for
the opportunity of speaking and we would
also like to thank the planning officer
for his hard work and comprehensive
committee report I wanted to use my time
to reiterate some of the key points and
benefits of the proposal which are set
out in the report as you've heard
permission already exists for five
dwellings on the site the existing
permission is a material consideration
but the starting point is the existing
situation on the ground which you've
seen through the photos the site is
brownfield and this has been confirmed
by the previous appeal inspector
national and local policy supports
brownfield redevelopment as your officer
states the neighbourhood plan provides
scope in principle for redevelopment of
brownfield sites outside of defined
boundaries and the appeal inspector
confirm this also the principle of
development is therefore fully
acceptable the site as you've seen in
the photos is covered by poor quality
buildings glass houses and hard standing
plus the meadow area this proposal would
see an 81 percent reduction in built
form across the site your officer
considers the proposal would enhance the
existing landscape character and
considers the design entirely
appropriate and varied the site as
you've heard lies in the Welford Western
buffer neighborhood plan policy 86
requires proposals not to reduce that
gap as can be seen on slide one and on
the screen and the site plan which
you've also seen this proposal will
improve the gap the comments which have
been made about plot six AB sorry plot
nine are sited on an existing building
so that is not part of the current green
space your officer calculates that there
would be an increase of twenty four
percent of this gap I'm aware of the
third-party objections in relation to
height of some of the dwellings
the tallest dwellings are plots five and
six these have been deliberately sited
internal to the development the height
of these properties is within within
approximately 10 centimeters of
dwellings nearby at bridle-path
Orchard lodge and coppers for photos of
these can be seen on slides two to four
levels also drop on the application site
some of the plots proposed are much
lower at 7.5 meters and your officer
considers the variety of Heights
suitable to the wider setting highway
state that the proposal will have a
significant benefit to the immunity of
the surrounding Road network by removing
the big spherical element of traffic
from the location the development
provides a variety of sizes of dwellings
from 2 beds to 4 beds and are certain
spacious plots which reflect the
surrounding character no trees are to be
removed and existing Gaffey boundary
hedgerow would be enhanced the meadow
would be retained and the development
would result in that biodiversity gained
as you've heard the development offers
improvements to neighbours by removal of
noise from traffic generated by the
current operations and plants a
machinery noise which also operates at
night a contribution of over two hundred
and ten thousand pounds to affordable
housing would be made along with
contribution to open space all these
points are set out in your officer
report and it's clear to me that there
are significant benefits of the
development which way in favor of the
proposal I hope you're able to support
your office the recommendation to grant
the application thank you thank you
any questions from the committee Kemp
slept pairing good evening I wonder
whether you could just pick up on a
comment that was made by the parish
council regarding the appeal decision
which advised that the built form
shouldn't extend beyond eastwards beyond
the the existing five dwellings yes so
the the appeal decision did comment on
that gap what the appeal in my view it
didn't rise or fall on the basis of was
any development where plotline is is
currently proposed it saw the
enhancement to this buffer zone the
green gap at the benefit of the proposal
the key point which I want to get over
this evening is that as you can see the
slide on the screen the left hand side
shows the existing green gap the right
hand side shows the proposed the
neighborhood plan policy just says there
must not be a reduction in the gap and
as you can see from what's shown there
would be an increase in the gap still it
might not be as much as the approved
appeal scheme that still would be an
improvement to that gap chairman can I
just come back with a supplementary with
regard to the housing needs survey the
parish council inferred that it didn't
marry or fit in with the new housing
needs survey can you just explain why
there hasn't been a consideration to the
housing needs survey I think the Paris
that have been adopted in the last
couple of months and the application was
submitted and the plans prepared quite
quite a few months ago but
notwithstanding that the the
neighborhood plan policy allows for
redevelopment of brownfield sites for
open-market dwellings outside of
physical confines in the village so
there is no stipulation that this should
be on-site affordable housing or local
market dwellings as such and we feel
that were provided a good mix of
dwellings because we've provided a two
beds and three beds and some four beds
any further questions yes counselor
Jennings just going up back onto the
trees hedgerows any other plans yes so
at the moment the obviously quite a lot
of boundaries to the site and some of
the hedgerows are better than others at
the moments there are some gaps within
parts of the hedgerows they would be
bolstered in as a condition for a
landscaping scheme than the neighbor who
spoke and mentioned this dangerous tree
that's the first I've heard it was a
conversation at committee this evening
where I think they advised the applicant
so I'm sure he will attend to that tree
is required but the landscaping scheme
would secure additional planting if
there are no further questions that case
thank you both very much
and we can get our final speaker on this
one the ward member counts the Barnes
welcome counselor we have five minutes
over to you
this site is not in the village boundary
it's out of the village boundary it is a
brownfield site which is situated
between Weston on the right and well put
on the left the River Road as you say is
on the right hand side and there a
footpath in a lot of areas we went on
the side business on the first
application
I think the senior officer you went and
the general opinion was that you know it
would tie do you talk it is used six
o'clock in the morning 30 cars come to
work and lorries are trying to get down
from the Maypole which is that little
road pass the Shakespeare walk down that
track and they usually bump or have been
known on a regular basis to bump into
cars because it's only a single track
road so in the 1960s I think it was at
guca sants and the Pope came to Ireland
and I think they made a fortune over the
croissants and they all went by rail
from Millcote station so in the old days
when everybody worked there there wasn't
a problem but as you can see in their
gender there are quite a lot of people
have written in support of this this
isn't what people do in houses we don't
want a lot of houses but a lot of people
feel that this is a lot better than
having the site as it is which is fully
occupied with beeping going on all the
time if you read in the thing
the county council also think that this
is a good idea because lorries in in the
village are not suitable the roads
aren't suitable for that so not only are
they not opposing it but they are
supporting it because of the access one
or two changes in the house
were made in the respected the ones near
the river were lowered a bit with
requests from Ludington and the Anglin
Valley whatever its called
but the river trust and we have now a
mix of houses where we had five five
bedroom asses before we now have nine
with some two and some three-bedroom
houses in the respect of the application
for the house that the opponents they're
opposed there is a big green house there
as you can see and the house will take
up I suppose
half the greenhouses but room but that
piece of ground is to meet is lower than
the road and the rest of the site so
from well put it's facing down this way
one thing I did ask for and I haven't
found out is that in the welfare plan
there is no cycle way to strapper from
Western you can cycle 14 to 17 minutes
to welcome along the bridleway and the
green way and I I asked the officer it's
a cycle way which I had actually asked
for and haven't followed up or not
regularly he's in there and the same I'm
supportive of it
I appreciate the parish council
situation we have got our quota he's out
of our area it may one day come into
Welford but if you look on the top where
the river is there's three four old
houses there which were for the workers
the workers that work there are still
there
they'd been retired some time and there
is still there so I could go on at
length but if you look at the difficult
to show you here but we have a mill cut
road which ones is the well food which
is where it says application sites on
the right hand side where we've at the
bottom there long there we've have a
number of applications where the
distance between Wellborn and Western
has been significant in in the reason
for refusal and that's why we want to
make sure that it isn't all houses it
has that gap and they have produced the
gap 15 didn't awarded on but I could go
on for some time but I hope you'll do
what the officers said with the
conditions and I asked if there is a
cycle way Thank You counsel
any questions for our ward member no
that case counts a bounce thank you very
much right that's what I speakers points
of clarification from the committee to
have any questions
councillor Perry thank you if I could
just have clarification on a number of
approximate sort of a number of
dwellings for infill I thought that was
sort of up to five and this is obviously
nine so can you just confirm
clarification for numbers of dwellings
for small infernal please
thank you yes sir there is no I would
say hard and fast definition of often a
small-scale site I would say obviously
this were guided by the inspector and
the appeal decision that's been issued
this has been deemed to be previously
developed brownfield land development on
such land searching on some points that
are made by previous speakers
development on such land of the site is
supported within the I'm guided by the
neighbor development plan separately in
areas of open countryside whereby if it
is a brownfield site development of a
suitable designer and whatnot will
actually be supported also within he6
obviously which deals with the gap
between Western and welfare separately I
would say any further point carry on
counseling unless somebody else would
like to pass something I was just
interested to know that if we were
minded to approve what would be the
situation on having superfast broadband
direct into the properties
Jim um I don't know whether Welford has
super fast brought back out if Welford
doesn't have super fast broadband this
site can't have superfast broadband you
can't expect this site to provide
superfast broadband well it doesn't
expect exist in the village but
certainly we can use conditions to
ensure that whatever speed is available
in Welford is available on this site and
we will be quite happy to do that I'm
not sure whether we've got a condition
that says that on the decision please
ask us to add it and we will do so any
other point yes counselor Adam um can we
just clarify councillor Barnes alluded
to the fact that the area in question is
actually outside the parish councils
area can we just get confirmation that
it is in the parish councils area and
thusly affected by its NDP please
that is correct the entirety of this
site is within well fits area as a
clause in the NDP and it's obviously
Western iski is not too far away right
if there are more points of
clarification should we go to the debate
have you want to start a sense council
apparel you're gonna jump nobody else is
sort of diving in there first
obviously it's very comprehensive report
I'm pleased to see on what appears to me
to be a high quality development that
there are some two and three-bedroom
units but the applicant hasn't just come
forward with very large properties which
is fairly typical in the Welford area so
there is you know the there are sand two
and three-bedroom properties it's good
to see that the area of green space has
been extended over part of the brown
field land area
and on the basis of what we have in
front of us and we have support from the
ward member I see no planning reasons
not to refuse so I'll be going with the
officers recommendation and happy to
propose grant before Thank You counsel
Eric would you add that condition as
well as part of your proposition I would
be it it would be on condition of that
sense of can't connectivity to the
existing facility and Welford village
okay
Thank You council Jennings in question
and the additional houses are mainly
made up of two and three bedrooms so I
that basis I'm very happy to second it
thank you cancel Jennings anybody else
want to speak from this I'll just add my
thoughts and we've got a proposition in
a second so it goes to the vote in a
second I think you've said everything
really counts the power you that you've
highlighted all the things what I would
say is particularly mayor I understand
your frustration with this but I think
given that we've already established the
principle of development and I think my
thinking is that if we if we weren't
look favorably at this weren't to look
favorably on this I think we'd end up
with another appeal sending off to
inspect the inspector would come back
and say well even plot line is still on
brownfield site and I think that so I
get the frustration from the neighbor
particularly here but I don't think we'd
really have a leg to stand on really so
for that reason I will go along with the
officers recommendation as well
could I ask you just to give us do you
have any rough wording that you would
use for the condition pensions I'm just
I don't I just think the way to deal
with it is to ask for the applicant to
submit proposals for the provision of
broadband because that can come with a
justification for White's proposing that
particular
and explain what the maximum bandwidth
is available or explore rather I could
also pick pardon which led to my senior
colleagues autopsy we could also be
guided by specific policy within the NDP
relating to that provision of broadband
separately flaws and proven that the
same wording right okay I'm happy with
that if you are as well right so
obviously I'll just draw members
attention to the update sheet as well
particularly condition 18 there's no
longer if consider that suggested
condition 18 is required so that won't
be part of the conditions you all seen
that so it's been proposed and seconded
with the additional condition regarding
broadband the removal of condition 18
that we grant this application all those
in favor of grants and please show thank
you that case the committee resolves to
grant application reference 90 in / 0 1
75 1 / ful we move to our next item
tonight so our next item is on 20 page
29 of your agendas
right so apologies that right welcome
back counselor Barnes this application
reference 19 slash zero one eight three
eight slash very is for home farm old
school Lane lights on and it's for a
variation of conditional two and six
relating to harm soft landscaping now
that before we go into a full-blown
presentation on this the update of
course is that the parish council have
removed their objection to this that was
the reason for this application coming
to committee the ward member is content
and actually even one of the speakers
who was going to come along isn't here
tonight now even usually our our effort
is to delegate these back to officers
however if committee would rather hear
the entire application you're more than
welcome to do so yes counselor Barnes
thank you I have a second counselor
Jennings a second thank you
there for the proposition is that we
delegate this about two officers for
them to make the decision felt all those
in favor please show thank you do I need
to say four words
application reference 19 slash zero one
eight three eight slash various
delegating back to officers right six
been recommended with the officer
recommendation for this applications you
just want to check that members are
happy for that to go on as well
presume you are everyone I'm getting
nods from around the table so this there
contend with that thank you okay
Papaji zero thanks right so then we've
got item 6 which has I believe been
withdrawn
is that correct there item six the
application yes Jack the item six
application nineteen stroke zero one
nine zero to four to five roles would
common has been withdrawn by the
applicant so the the application
no longer exists that case moved to item
7 found on page 53 of your agenda right
okay let's get started again there so
this is application reference 19 slash 0
0 1 6 9 / ful and it's for Dean cottage
well Lane Tanith Nardin and it's the
replacement replacement dwelling with
integral garage and associated works
presenting officers to apply it again
sure that you Thank You chairman the
chair said I've seen this application is
for a replacement dwelling associated
works this is an amended proposal to an
extent permission under reference 0 8 4
/ 0 to 109 4 / ful the application site
is outside of the village of tamatha
Nardin in an area washed over by the
West Village Greenbelt the application
cited which is indicated by this black
dots on your screen here we see the
application sites outlined in red here
today
once one can see that this location
panel also incorporates an 18 house
scheme at tank farm that was approved by
reserve matters earlier this year and as
you can see by the blue line is in the
same land ownership as the applicants as
this application is evening here we see
a proposed block plan showing the
revised replacement dwelling the subject
of this application again in the context
of how it would sit next to be already
approved dwellings at crank farm here we
have the proposed elevations of the
replacement dwelling we now have some
photos of the site and its surroundings
here we are stood on existing access
tract that would be used to access the
application sites to the left just up
here
mesh fencing you can see here is
currently on the right ceiling off the
tank farm sites here we're now stood a
lot further southwards
now looking at where the proposed
replacement darling would be sited one
can see mature trees that line of
southern boundary of the site here we're
now stood within the application so
itself
now looking eastwards down a slope
overlooking large sways of open
countryside here to the east here we are
now stood in approximately the same spot
now looking westwards towards the tank
farm residential development past this
mesh mesh fencing here the proposed
replacement dwelling is the search of
this application it's been marginally
more cubic volume than has already been
approved a previous approve that offices
are satisfied it has materially
commenced officers are also satisfied
that the external emission would not be
would be implementable if permission for
this scheme this evening we're not
forthcoming the scheme is deemed to be
acceptable when considering matters of
principle character and appearance and
more and officers recommendation to
members this evening supplicating faxes
and reflects this chairman the
recommendation is to grant for the
reasons 2,000 pages 61 of your agenda
thank you all right Thank You Stuart
okay we have only one speaker I believe
on this its councillor Mike solders tan
with an ardent parish council please
welcome hello please do take a seat yes
that's fine thank you if you press the
button right in the middle of that there
you go
you don't need to get too near to the
mic you pick up quite comfortably from a
distance way right so welcome Council
you have three minutes if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end and
I'll give you a warning the last 15 or
10 seconds I can report this would be a
slam dunk grant permission I'd like to
make three points first of the pair
counts was really concerned somehow from
1992 when those
site no longer there I think we had
established residential use has now
become if he obviously recommendations
implemented a five bedroom detached
house whose Dominus through a series of
permissions with a condition the
committee development rights were
removed because of a concern it should
not get any larger being in the green
belt etc house with a garage and now to
a fight veteran second point you refer
to extant permission now I may be wrong
about this but top of the dictionary
extant means existing but the 2008
permission including the phrase replies
had the condition has through all
Planning Commission's the development
must be begun within five years and he
wasn't so unless I'm wrong the
permission has expired so there was no
entitlement to build anything on this
side at present that obviously you
wouldn't want to refuse something unless
somehow circumstances were changed
2008-10 farm has now got detailed
planning permission delegated officers
report on the detailed made two
important points first that they
consider that the scale of development
was inappropriate in the Greenbelt it
was in fact double what was there before
whereas it outlined the indication was
it would be much the same
and said where are they leaving very
special circumstances that over right
back
they looked all the other relevant
matter is in one of them the report
states volume and density is very large
with the remnant on the edge of a
village
not organic and was already said
necessarily because they're in the same
okay
their permission there yes I think maybe
that's on the on the on the plan I think
it shows that the the permissions for
the houses but they've not been built
yet okay right capsule apparent good
evening
does time within Hardin parish council
have a housing needs survey at all and
when was that last undertaken
2016 maybe seven right and principally
what what did that sort of did you'd
identify further need for a five-bedroom
property to progress to completion yes
the critical issue in Tamara is the loss
of smaller okay there are no further
questions that case Council Saunders
thank you for your time tonight Thank
You captain we don't have a woman
because of course character addiction
you are continuing on the committee for
this so we moved two points of
clarification do we have any questions
counsel Dixon first I'll make the first
person to mr. clarity obviously the
Parish Council are basically saying that
in their view the permission that was
granted has not commenced development
within the specified period how do we
evidence that it did indeed commence
coming back to the extant is another
question of extant permission so what's
actually happened on side thank you yes
officers of course was considered
counselor that's a key consideration we
are satisfied that's been reflecting
your agenda fact that development as
indeed commenced and it would commence
within the five years that was granted
for that permission through the
demolition of the dwelling and also
through the force of detailing or panic
history section some conditions have
been discharged on that permission so we
are satisfied and comfortable that that
permission is indeed extent and still is
to this day correct
thank you Karen Jennings set you a
question two
so are there any other if there are
other points of clarification should we
go to the debate it doesn't be not to
start us off here caps bonds it looks
like there isn't anything rounded
anybody else catch the dicks and then
counts our power basically obviously
this this application is just outside
the village envelope it will and it
sorts the site will be incorporated into
the built-up area boundary should that
actually go through unchanged but it
certainly is proposed to be within the
built-up area boundary for the village
such as a site the development of tank
farm which is in the same ownership and
has got permission and basically for 18
properties those properties range from
five bedrooms four bedrooms down to
three bedroom this property my
understanding essentially is that the
volume is very similar or even that
which is above ground even less than
that which has already got permission
perhaps mr. Flaherty can confirm that
that is the case because obviously there
is underground or at least basement
garage in being incorporated on this
application which was not on the
previous permitted application my
understanding so I must admit I have
don't have any issue against this
particular one because essentially it
will be in more keeping with the
eighteen houses which in due course may
get developed the site has permission
it's empty
nothing seems to be happening at the
present time and there's even rumors
that it's up for sale but that was under
more than rumors okay I think before
come to your council power if I can just
we had a question in terms of what was
there before how much bigger is this
time it's the size belt of mats
what's the difference I'm happy to
clarify that chair thank you the front
elevation as you see here as would be
visible from the access road is actually
six hundred mill lower than the approved
dwelling to the ridge that's an
important consideration as is reflected
in the report obviously we consider the
matters of the Greenbelt clearly and
what's whether it's deemed to be
materially larger than the extent
replacement dwelling the cubic volume is
such that it's three percent larger in
volume that's largely by virtue of the
fact that this is now an integral
carriage the previous approval had I
have got visuals need be but they're
prevented in the previous extent removal
had a replacement dwelling and then had
a ford projecting detached garage
separately so the quantum of those two
structures is only three percent smaller
than its currently put before you this
evening for this replacement volume and
some of what's before is this evening is
subdivisions yes correct
council Perry did you indicate Thank You
chair based on what we've had presented
before us I'm fully aware the planning
officers if they if they ever have any
doubt about Greenbelt they were always
the first to sort of say this is a
really big issue
I'm therefore minded to be guided by the
officers on this particular one I'm
comforted by the fact that the the
increased volume is because of by nature
of its subterranean design and therefore
I'm happy to go with the officers
recommendation and propose to speak on
this well yes of course yes he is if
he's allowed to sit on the committee
give him idiot I am
that's okay so this proposal seconded I
think I'd add my thoughts which I
completely agree with what's been said
already and actually I'd go a little bit
further to say I think it's a very
impressed
design I think it's been imaginatively
put together and it's taken account of
what was required and very carefully I
think that the designers have done a
very good job I'm quite impressed with
it actually so I'm happy to support the
officers on this one as well so it's
been proposed um it's been seconded am
ii could draw your attention to the fact
that there's an additional condition
recommendation for an additional
condition be included requiring further
details of road access from the site of
well lane as long as you're all aware of
that as well
and that's been taken into account
should we go to the vote it's been
proposed that we would grant permission
all those in favor please show 5-channel
those against and abstentions thank you
okay the committee therefore is resolved
to grant permission for application
reference 19 / 0 0 1 6 9 / ful we move
to item 8
just for the delay there right okay so
item eight page 65 two applications here
but they're related to the same site so
it's 18 / 0 3 7 9 7 / ful and 18 / 0 3 7
9 8 / lb soon as you plug it back in
right well I can continue to read this
off so this is the kartoffel glebe farm
Mill Lane
Ashtyn kempler so the full application
is retrospective application for
enlargement of roof light installation
of a satellite dish and the listed
building consent is for the retention of
roof lights satellite dish together with
internal operations to enable the use of
loft space as additional residential
accommodation presenting officer is Erin
Wilson thank you to you the application
site lies to the south of Aston can play
village in open countryside as
identified by the black dot on this plan
just here public footpath il-76 lies to
the west of the site and is shown by the
green dashed line just going down here
this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red this area here site
lies within the West Midlands Greenbelt
and the art and special landscape area
the site also lies within the
conservation area which is shown by the
pink line on this plan so the pink line
just going around here and back up
property is a former cart house which
formed one of a number of our buildings
associated with gleamed farmhouse which
was just here in 2010 planning
permission an Associated listed building
consent was granted for the conversion
of four outbuildings to dwellings the
works included the conversion of the
cart house which is now known as a cart
hovel as part of the 2010 plan
information permitted development rights
part 1 & 2 were removed the main
farmhouse and the building which is a
subject of this application are both
grade 2 listed as shown by the red
shading for these are the listed
buildings here plan information a list
of building consent to sought for the
retention of a large roof lights and the
installation of a satellite
these works are retrospective listed
building consent is also sought for the
insertion of internal glazing this slide
to the satellite image of the
application site the application site is
outlined in red just here access to the
site shown to the west and to the south
to the north of the image is gleave
farmhouse which is great too you lift it
just here and it also shows the
neighboring buildings which were
converted which is a quest of buildings
here so the other outbuildings this
slide shows a previously pre-planned as
part of the conversion of the cart house
along the top for different elevations
and the roof flights that were
previously approved so you can see here
and three on this elevation the plans
along the bottom show the proposed
elevations part of this application you
can see the enlarged roof light here the
satellite dish on the end of elevation
and the changes to the roof lights on
the side elevation here compared to the
previously approved scheme this slider
is a photograph looking Northwest across
at the cluster of buildings from the
access road the cart Hubble can be seen
in the centre of the image just here and
you can see the roof light on the facing
roof slope and the satellite dish here
this slider it's a photographic was
taken from the garden at the cart Hubble
and the roof light is visible here and
the satellite dish to the right-hand
side of this image this lighter is a
photograph taking looking at the North
facing elevation of the cart hovel you
can see the 3 roof lights in this facing
roof slope and a satellite dish on the
end elevation just there there are
internal changes which list listed
building consent is thought for this
includes the installation of a glazed
area which you can see here upper
glazing and lower glazing you can see on
the section you've got the ground floor
and the first floor it's this area here
you can see in a section this area here
an insulator is a photograph of where
the glazing would go so that the upper
glazing here and the lower glazing in
the lower section proposed external
works are not considered to respect the
simple form of a host building and yet
in the absence of any public benefits
are considered of course
in substantial harm to designated
heritage facets the development is also
considered calls visual harm to the
rural character the area and the art and
special landscape area does air-cool
recommended the plan information and
listed building consent are refused for
the reason set out in the office of
report thank you Thank You Erin
right our first speaker them and I've
councillor Leslie Harvey from Aston
cantaloupe parish council welcome
councillor so you have three minutes if
you'd arranged seated for any questions
at the end give you a warning at the
last ten seconds okay I think from our
perspective there are a number of
concerns in a number of considerations
within the report you will all have read
that the current owner and the applicant
who is applying for retrospective
permission is not the person that
install those windows they were
installed at the time the development
was made and this wasn't picked up we
feel quite strongly that it's wrong to
penalize somebody that now owns a
building for something that was the
fault of the people that developed it at
that time we also understand that the
likelihood is that the satellite dish
was also installed at the same time
because all of the other properties in
that development have satellite dishes
and they're not being asked to remove
them again discrepancy in planning and
in its application we when you walk
around that development this bond sits
right to the back it's not overlooked by
anything we don't believe that the
existing windows actually are to the
detriment of it or its surroundings at
all and we're quite keen on retaining
the conservation area within our village
and within the parish however that said
we don't believe that really looks
anything like a pond anymore nor did we
at the time it was developed
particularly the development itself is
beautiful when you go inside
then absolutely meticulously done and we
don't think that the internal glazing
actually does much damage to the
existing way it looks or the format or
the construction of the building it's
something that can be replaced and
returned to its original so it's it's
not that they're taking beams out it's
purely that they're putting some glass
panels in to allow light into what is
currently an unusable space we should
say that the bond itself is quite tiny
and at the time the applicant purchased
it we understand that they were given to
believe that that they would probably
get permission to do some of the work
we're very impressed by the fact that
the applicant has tried to work very
closely with the officers previous
recommendations there used to be a
purpler to the side of that which
actually was made of oak and it was a
very attractive in our view piece of
garden however the officer wanted it
removed they removed it they've they've
gone a long way to try and accommodate
but the restoration of those windows
will do a lot more damage to the roof in
our opinion then leaving them as there
as they are ten seconds nobody else's
has made any objections and therefore we
would urge you to flex your I was gonna
say muscle words probably in another
right word the flexibility that you have
to exert that flexibility please and
recommend branch at this application
thank you very much thank you cancer so
do we have any questions for the parish
council no that case thank you very much
okay we could now to the planning agent
mr. Gary Moss please
an applicant Marcus hunter
and take it mr. moss you're doing most
of the talking mr. hunt you're here for
questions lovely stuff that case mr.
moss you have three minutes over to you
thank you very much I hope you're going
to take up over that time just wanted to
make a few points there obviously my
clients brought this property on the
understanding that all the works to the
exterior of the building were approved
you'll see for the report the officers
have made quite clear that was amended
plans submitted there was clearly a bit
of a miscommunication as to what the
plans should have been showing and what
was actually approved but we accept we
are where we are the key thing is my
client hasn't had taken quite a bit of
works in line in consultation with the
council's conservation officer the
actual windows which are the big area
and if possible could the officer go
back to the internal photograph because
one of the things that the parish
council picked up we can see just from
that photo how dark and small this
property is the four roof lights that
were previously approved would give
little or no light to this property it
really is quite dark then roof lights
that are there really do benefit it my
client also is looking for extra space
to basically and their families growing
so we're not looking for major
extensions or works to this building and
really the harm is negligible if
anything and I would concur with the
comments of the parish council that
actually to carry out these works now
giving us the nearly 10 years would
actually be more harmful to that
building and take a further 10 years for
those works to sort of blend back into
the building finally with regards a
satellite dish there is no other option
for aerials other than we believe the
conservation officer dwelling it to be
mounted on a pole in the garden that
clearly to us is unacceptable and would
it be far more detrimental to the
conservation area in the setting than
the smaller shots there so
and if you've got your questions happy
to help thank you well thank you
do we have any questions from the
committee capsule bonds sort of check-in
that these lights windows comply with
the conservation I think if you referred
to the conservation style roof lights
yes they are
translation roof lights they're just
larger and in a slightly different
location to be approved mister building
consent councillor Perry good evening I
just wonder whether you can give some
clarification on when when the property
was purchase was that just direct from
the developer or was it already
previously developed and then it was a
second in 2016 it was in place in
application to change is when all this
came to light well if there are no other
questions gentlemen thank you very much
we have no ward member registered for
this so points of clarification anybody
got any questions
councillor Barnes then Chancellor Perry
no we're just checking the satellite
dish and the windows are incorporated
together could be approved woman or not
another we have to consider the
development before it is proposed that
have been amendments during the course
of the application so there are no
objections to the internal works now
from the conservation officer but we've
got to look at the roof lights that
proposed and the satellite dish because
that's before us
vectored yes counselor Perry then I've
got council Dixon can I just have
clarification from from a legal
perspective and this might be want
something for Farrah Ross if if when the
owner purchased this property there was
nothing on the property information
forms that highlighted reference to this
particular development the windows where
where where does it where do we stand
from looking at it from a planning
perspective and what if what what
recourse potentially is there if we were
to refuse it for the owner to go back to
the perspective on the it's not
individual to sort of it's it's not a
relevant consideration for your planning
judgment today councillor Dixon Thank
You chairman questions very the
applicant indicated that in their
opinion that if the satellite dish was
on the pole that would be even worse do
you concur with that opinion during the
course of the application it's in the
officer report as well we've had no
evidence and the conservation officer
lifted it that it couldn't be cited
somewhere else so we haven't had the
document to say it has to be there we
haven't had in the evidence it couldn't
be cited anywhere else so we can't give
any weight to that so we've had to look
at what's proposed and the conservation
officer finds that harmful and the roof
lights as well so like I said in this
case we haven't had any evidence it
wouldn't be practical anywhere else and
it's quite a simple form in terms of the
building and the conservation officers
concerned about this disrupting the
simple form and the special interest
the host building just to follow up on
that if I'm a chair at the the applicant
is carefully set up an image in your
mind of a satellite dish on a pole which
is ridiculous it doesn't have to be on a
pole there are various possibilities of
where a satellite including on the
ground so there are other options there
is no reason to I have no planning
answer to that chairman except that 5g
is rolling out yeah right
so my point is clarification which we go
to the debate who wants to start
gilad Council Perry all right it's back
to me again I think first of all I have
terrific sympathy with the property
owner number one and I understand the
parish council are clearly trying to do
everything they can to help the property
owner who is has been caught up in all
this but and it's clear that this should
have been particularly for grade 2
listed properties any developer ought to
know that it has to conform with strict
planning conditions as much as I would
like
to be persuaded to grant on
retrospective I'm afraid I have to go
with the principle with the conservation
officer I think they could do something
wrong satellite dish it could be put on
the ground hands tied behind my back I'm
gonna have to go with the officers
recommendation Thank You Council Perry
nobody else want to speak on this
council Jennings Dixon I'd really
struggle on some things when you look at
it in this thing logic we should just
does it really matter no one can see it
it's sort of it's been there for over 10
years the window in the satellite dish
to me it's not a problem I know it's
gonna go north a lot of disruption
changing these windows and putting them
back as to how this should have been
done rich and then it just seems crazy
that there isn't some sort of compromise
or way of getting rounded I'm really
struggling on it but I'm still thinking
I'm still thinking if you just permit me
a second oh I'm just trying okay when
you figures good back to maybe Dale
Aaron when when where did this happen
when will these alterations made there's
another statute of limitations in the in
terms of picking up on these in terms of
immunity from enforcement action because
the building is listed it there is a
time period associated with it so we're
considering these is an authorized wax
okay
so presents so normally it'd be five
years but because of this list forever
because it's listed yes it doesn't have
the same immunity time limits
councillor Dixon sorry for cutting you
off no problem tonight my chairman I
think we as a planning authority and
it's an enforcement authority had a
responsibility when we actually grant
permissions in respective listed
buildings to try and ensure that it is
follows through here a developer builder
who ever converted it ten years ago has
not done what they should have done it
is to the detriment of the current owner
I personally don't find much wrong with
what I am looking at the satellite dish
is minimal the skylights obviously have
got the greater impact but I do not find
that offensive and therefore I would not
be supporting the officers
recommendation catch the bugs you know
it's a difficult situation and we have
to support the conservation architecting
in some respects but because this has
been done and the right windows are
going to be put in I would be quite
happy to support the windows I don't see
it personally anything wrong with the
dish but I'm God happy to go along with
it on the loudspeaker if you if you feel
that would be helpful right I'll add my
thoughts at this point because council
Dixon Katz Barnes I think I'm with you
on this
it's a finely balanced one and I
recognize that this is in the
conservation area ordinarily now I'm not
I don't whether or not this was done by
the present owner previous era that's
have no matter to me actually I'm
looking in in this case at the harm that
is done by the different roof lights and
the placement of the satellite dish
which may or may not be there forever
depending on technological improvements
what is my where am I going with this
where are we all go that's what is the
serious harm now realize we have very
very clear policies set out on this one
but I'm trying to find the real harm
that's being done by this application
and I can't find it I don't and it's
very helpful having the parish council
here as well because ordinarily in a
case like this I'd want to listen to the
local voices of the local
representatives of the people and that
of course is the parish council in this
case and you've course who kept the
council you made your statement earlier
on about how you think it's unfair but
you also very clearly in your original
submission say that you don't find it to
be sufficient harm caused by these
changes to the building so that gives me
consolation that actually I think you
know this is something that you would
support but on a visual basis as well
you don't find there to be the harm come
mine did you take a steer from the
parish council therefore on this
occasion so I'm content to propose that
we actually grant this application I'd
been looking for a seconder for that
tell you're about to ask me for my
reasons
I expect yes I don't find to be that you
can have to help me with the policy
numbering on this but I don't find that
to be sufficient harm to the setting of
the conservation area from this proposal
can you help me a little bit the
critical issue here is the the advice
the guidance and laws that the
government of given us is that if
anything causes harm to the significance
of a listed building it should not be
granted unless there is a corresponding
public benefit so the way your
conservation officer has approached this
is they've identified ha
they've looked for a public benefit and
found no public benefit that will remain
your conservation officers view that
there is harm if you look at this and
you feel the the size and pattern of the
windows and the positioning of the
satellite dish cause no harm you are
entitled to come to that conclusion in
coming to that conclusion you don't need
to find any public benefit
you can simply conclude that it causes
no harm and grant permission policies
all right yes thank you I'm being
reminded by Aaron there are three
reasons so cs9 is the first reason that
we're using to refuse it to suggest that
it isn't a high quality architectural
design it isn't set it's sensitive to
the setting or existing built form you
can conclude that it is a high quality
architectural design it is sensitive to
its setting etc etc as required by cs9
if you so wish the other two reasons
refusal are protecting and enhancing the
district's historic environment cs6
again you are entitled to conclude that
it does protect and enhance the
districts in her historic environment
and comply with si si si si si si si s 8
and finally special landscaping area
protected by resisting development that
would have a harmful effect on their
distinctive character again you can
conclude that it doesn't have a harmful
effect on the distinctive character and
therefore it complies with CS 12 so what
I'm saying is there are policies CS 9 CS
8 and CS 12 which you can conclude it
does comply with if you so wish
notwithstanding the advice
thank you I think that's what that's
definite what's in my mind I'm just
failing to see the harm and therefore
I'm finding that it with these sort of
can often be in a beauty have beholder
and I'm choosing to believe that
actually it doesn't cause too much harm
at all and actually I think there might
be public benefit of you if you look at
them
does this make the building tenable does
it make it sustainable as a dwelling as
a youth would it fall out of use now no
that's hypothetical and and not be used
here but I find that to be a public
benefit as well so I think it actually
makes that a sustainable building going
forward exactly so I find that it is it
is acceptable so I counsel Jennings
could could you argue at all will be
done to enlisted buildings roof by
trying to change it back I think if
there's anybody else wanting to speak at
this point important point is the penny
TS caps antics just a question really is
given that what we're actually looking
at presumably was the result of the
conversion the improvement and the
enhancement of the building has got to
be presumably not against its current
form or its proposed form but its
original form and as a regional form it
was prior to conversion and therefore we
can't see other than say that is quite
an attractive building
yes I mean I see where you're coming
from right I proposed it it's been
seconded by Councillor Dix and I need to
say it's councillor Dixon because you've
not even you said yes now that we need
because they're the two parts of this we
have to deal with them separately so we
have to vote on them separately so I'm
proposing that we grant the 18 Slash's 0
3 7 ounce 1 7 / ful and it's been
seconded by councillor Dixon all those
in favor please share again of course
final conditions to be agreed through
the chair obviously with chair all those
in favor against and abstentions thank
you okay let's do the second one of the
listed building consent again happened
to propose that so that's I'm proposing
18 / 2 0 3 7 9 8 / LBC seconded by
councillor Dixon all those in favor of
that as well five German thank you and
those against 10 abstentions thank you
so therefore the committee has resolved
to approve both of these applications 18
/ 0 3 7 9 7 / ful and 18 / 0 3 7 9 8 /
lbc of course those conditions to come
back to me and say at some point in the
future right okay on to our final
application for the light this is item 9
okay I found on page 75 of your agendas
so application reference 19 / 0 2 3 5 7
/ ful this is for 31 college lanes
Stratford a blatem this the description
is for the resubmission of the
construction of first floor rear
extension the creation of a Juliet
balcony to the rear with a small pitch
dormer the changes and replacements
replacement of an existing flat roof on
an existing rear projection and changes
to fenestration and minor internal
changes rights present the office of
Orion O'Keefe right over to you Thank
You chairman the application property is
an end of terrorists two-story property
within the Old Town character area of
stratford-upon-avon and within the
conservation area the property is
constructed of red brick set beneath a
slate pitched roof have previously been
extended towards the rear the work the
proposed includes a first floor rear
extension a new dormer Giulia balcony to
the rear but an obscure glazed screen on
the rear elevation removal of existing
shadow pitch to roof from the rear
ground floor and replacement of a flat
roof with replacement windows and doors
that match the existing dwelling along
with minor internal changes so you can
see the side extension proposed on this
elevation along with the changes to the
link projection of the dwelling by here
on the arrow and on the front of the
dwelling you can see the reinstatement
of the brick arched window and a new
door to match what's already within that
Terrace
and again on this elevation you can see
the changes to the windows to be more
coherent and then here you can see the
changes to the rear of the property the
main issues are design impact and
conservation area and the listed
buildings and neighbor impact so you can
see the property as you approach from
College Street looking down toward
College Lane with the property right in
front of you it's important notes
obviously you can see the existing gable
with the later addition brickwork to the
left hand side there as well then this
is looking from the alley looking back
up towards the property with a link
projection on your left hand side and
then looking up to where lien Phil
Extension is and then this is taken from
the rear of the property with the window
in question and the other brickwork it
is important to note that that window
while obscure glazed on the plans during
the course of the submission has been
changed to a clear glazed window which
was historically clear raised as well
under permitted development and this is
the view from the current window which
would be replaced and blocked up to
accommodate the new extension again
apology fully but you can't control the
weather yeah there you go
thank you thank you right okay so our
first speaker counselor Ian fragile
speaking on behalf of the town council
please
welcome counselor hi so you you know the
routine you've got three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end over to you
the Town Council thinks that the
proposed larger fenestration French
doors and Juliet balcony on the rear
elevation is contrary to cs9 since it
would likely cause unjú overlooking and
overbearing to the immediate neighbors
over and above the existing fenestration
but the tiny supplication came to the
town council there was no comment made
by the conservation officer so the Town
Council requested that views the views
of the conservation of us should be
sought on the basis that this
development will be prominent within the
conservation area there has been no
report back to the Town Council of the
conservation officers view and as I
yesterday there was no statement made on
the planning system the Town Council
believe that residents should be given
every opportunity to be able to engage
in planning decisions before those
decisions are made and as such the tank
council I've considered the proposals
carefully and listen to concerns raised
by the neighbors and so we would like to
request that this application is refused
Thank You councillor any questions from
the committee no that kids council
tragedy thank you very much we go to an
objection and Natasha de Silva speaking
on behalf of next-door neighbor please
welcome thank you for waiting
you also have three minutes if you'd
like to remain seated for any questions
at the end over to you good evening I am
here this evening to object the proposed
scheme at thirty-one college lane on
behalf of my clients the mall vex
who live at number 32 my clients sole
concern is the proposed installation of
the Juliet balcony window with dormer to
the rear of the property as you can see
on the elevations that currently in this
location is a small bathroom window it
is proposed to replace this with a full
height clear gaze fully open Herbal
Juliet balcony bedroom window
this will allow direct overlooking into
my clients private garden space severely
harming their immunity and resulting in
a complete loss of privacy which
contravenes policy cs9 in his report the
officer indicates that the existing and
proposed windows are directly comparable
and that potential for overlooking will
not be significantly increased we do not
agree replacing the obscure glazing
we've caught with a clear glass we'll
still stop direct overlooking because of
the low height of the window head the
Juliet balcony also we have provided
photos at the mirroring window in number
32 to demonstrate this there at the end
of your saying the Juliet balcony window
head is not comparable as it is
substantially raised from the height of
the window head currently which is five
foot one inches high and it raised to 6
foot 10 inches which will inevitably
lead to increased overlooking and a
complete loss of privacy for neighbors
on both sides of number 31 the obscure
glazed balustrade does nothing to
mitigate this issue the officer has
failed to acknowledge that a dormer roof
extension has been included for the sole
purpose of raising the roof height to
allow the head of the window to be
raised considerably this will allow
people to stand fully upright at the
window enabling them to access and have
direct views into the rear gardens of
the surrounding properties it should be
noted that the existing overlooking the
officer refers to does not mean that
further additions which exacerbate
overlooking and loss of privacy are
automatically acceptable as per policy
cs20 the planning authority has a duty
to protect neighbour immunity from loss
of privacy
during discussions with the officer he
stated that the doorman was acceptable
as the as the dormer had already been
approved on the second floor however a
previous m4 dormers at first full level
was refused the decision especially
refers to the inappropriate of inclusion
of a dormer which as I quote would
neither preserve nor enhance the
character and appearance of the
conservation area but severely detract
from it due to the inappropriate design
location and form of the dormers we
accept that the Juliet balcony will be
located on the rear elevation but
maintain that impacts on the
conservation area should be considered
equally for any development in the
designating area regardless of whether
it's on the principal elevation or not
in light of the noted conflicts with the
adopted policy the president of dormer
refusal set by the previous application
and the valid concerns of neighbors
town council and the ward member we
respectfully request that you refuse
this application I am happy to answer
any questions you may have thank you
okay do we have any questions from the
committee
councillor Barnes well as you can see by
the window there it's just a normal
window part I mean it slides open yes
but not enough to fit your body out of
with the Juliet balcony you open the
whole thing up your whole body can in
theory lean outside the balustrade and
look completely around you can't do that
with a small bathroom window that's only
here yes any other questions
well in that case thank you very much
thank you Michelle drew the applicant
please is our next speaker
welcome thank you for waiting so you
have a six minute switch the combination
the previous two speakers time so that's
okay you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end
over to you thank you the proposal is
part of an ongoing project to renovate
this very rundown property and make a
safe and comfortable family home the
period features have been retained and
unsympathetic modern additions have
being the move wherever possible the
design features have been chosen to
complement the architecture of Old Town
and to improve the general appearance of
the property this application was
previously submitted last November the
window design was subsequently amended
to address my neighbors concerns but it
was not accepted
I had a site meeting in April with
councilor freshly this was wife and was
who were supporting the objections to
discuss the design and try and mediate a
compromise solution but the only offer
forthcoming was not something subject to
planning and so no solution could be
found as the application would have been
seven months in the planning system by
the hearing date I was advised to
withdraw the application which I did am
I now reapply today for those elements
that were not covered by permitted
development the proposal is to enlarge a
rear bedroom by adding an infill
extension removing one window and
changing the other to an inward opening
French window with a safety screen under
a doormat the room is small and the
designs are practical solutions to these
challenging spaces the proposed the
proposed extension is the size of a
double bed with a foot of space at the
bottom the ceiling is low unsleeping the
proposed dormer raises the ceiling at
the eaves my foot and a 30 centimeters
to create a small 2 meter high area
where there's room to stand and dress
the inward opening French windows the
Juliet balcony let light into the room
and by being vertical minimized the
amount of glass at eye level they also
give access onto the first floor for
furniture which will not fit up the
narrow winding stairs and although this
is referred to as a Juliet balcony the
window doesn't have
balcony and it's not possible to step
outside or to see any further
Ram dam from the existing under the
existing window has been subscribed to
describe today as a bathroom window it
is just a small opening casement which
is clear glazed
although I note that in a lot of the
comments on the e planning its described
as obscure glaze this is not the case
it's also notice that they describe this
window is small it is but those planes
are larger than the ones proposed in the
replacement French window French windows
on first floor level our fan throughout
Old Town and the proposed design
references to similar sets of Windows
that can be seen from the garden of the
property and although a railing would
have been in more keeping with a local
style an obscure glass screen has been
proposed and that was to mitigate the
concerns expressed that a full-length
window would increase the perception of
being overlooked although clearly an
obscure obscure screen at waist height
will not actually change the view from
my level as you can see no more standing
at a tall window than you counted
assuring them and although we cannot
exactly say how this room may be used in
future Eric's life experience tells us
that back bedrooms are generally not
places where people spend a great deal
of time standing at the window all the
properties on College Lane and new
Street have rear bedroom windows of
various shapes and sizes and all have
clear glass at eye level and all look
down upon their own gardens and parts of
their neighbor's gardens it is in the
nature of Old Town from our windows we
can look down on gardens and conversely
that from our Gardens we can look up at
windows all our properties are both
overlooked and overlooking and changing
the shape of a window does not change
that I believe the proposed changes to
be modest in size in keeping with the
local style and to improve the
appearance of the property while
reducing the number of
windows on the elevation and therefore
the amount of glass after I level I hope
the committee will find it so - and
choose to support it
thank you very much does the committee
have any questions
yes capsule Dixon you mentioned
obviously the Juliette bout read this
one does not have a balcony to actually
go out on can you explain you may have
covered it but if you did I'm sorry I
missed it what is the advantage of a
Juliette window over a standard window
if essentially you can't actually step
out onto a balcony given that you have
mentioned that you've tried to enhance
the property with reinstating period
features etc I'm not aware that Juliet
balconies are a period feature to be
replaced
perhaps in completely sexy French
windows at first level that I can see
from the garden and other properties so
there are some about but the main reason
is to let maximum amount of light in by
having the windows this way rather than
having them that way which would use a
lot the wall space and increase the
amount of glass eye level so I can get
more light by having a French window
floor-to-ceiling and also allows
furniture to come in if you needed to
get a large piece of furniture in on the
stairs are you saying chairman that the
Juliet window is a French window because
he says the two doors were French window
and then the Juliet is that just the
name of having a railing or a piece of
glass on the outside to stop these
falling out there's nothing to stand on
okay yeah that's fine
any other question capsule Jennings
what's your visibility like into a
neighbor's garden at the moment at the
moment if you open that window at the
back there you can see the far end of
the neighbor's garden I can't see this
patio area I can see a little bit of
that grass and I can see the bottom end
at present I think I have to be seen
from the dog looking spots are Perry
thank you good evening um your neighbors
window on that first on that first floor
is is that glazed and can they see into
your garden aunt Biddy's guys I think
they've got blinds out because it's a
bathroom window but yes they would is it
is it obscured glaze it appears to be
clear with a with a blind behind it
it hasn't been in this on fine company
right now the questions from the
committee that case thank you very much
for your time right we'll move them to
points of clarification any questions
oh we can go straight to the debate
okay there's a refusal that was right
that was raised earlier on by one of the
objectors on page 77 under relevant
history my question really is could we
just get a bit more clarification on
what that was so I think we've got here
extension to form additional
accommodation at ground
first of all level direction of boundary
walk and you give me a bit more
information on that what was that let's
go back quite a while the main point in
the planning history for them two
applications it firstly to establish the
historic nature of that window which was
clear glazed the to plan history both in
97 1 that was approved and one that was
refused with namely as I'll get to it
just a second one with for a dormer to
the roof and one with four alterations
to create a sort of mansard alteration
but the main thing in regards to these
permissions for IRS's of planning
officer was to establish the use of that
window in the rear and its historic
nature which is indicated to be clear
glazed and that's why we've made
reference to that planning history so it
shows clearly that that room has always
been used yes and it's not you know it's
not been obscured glazed perhaps I can
clarify that chair this pointer got lots
of left-hand column because I can't lay
the pointer there it isn't that is a
cross-section of the roof of the
application that was refused as you can
see the proposal would effectively and
turned it into a flat-roofed house with
dormice front and rear that was refused
the proposal that was approved is on the
right-hand side here for that flat roof
dormer there which you'd seen in the
photographs you've seen that that is
clear glazed and that that does provide
an element of overlooking
for the neighboring property and that's
been taken into account in the offices
assessment and that's how we've come to
our recommendation any other points of
clarification should we go to the debate
cats Lipari Thank You chairman this is
clearly a very controversial application
and I would feel more comfortable with a
deferral and a site visit to see to
actually see it from both points to be
fair to both the applicant and the
objectors
I don't feel from looking at the plans
and the windows I can make a proper
assessment without going on-site counsel
Jenny was living in the streets that in
a town city and you're gonna be able to
see into your neighbor's gardens it's
it's just a fact if you don't want if
you don't want anyone to look into your
garden then live near someone who's next
to them on this one from what I can see
you can see down an extra Juliet window
whether younger eyes on your knees it
makes no difference whether it's long it
just lets see more light I really
haven't got a problem with this at all
else at this point working on I've been
honest I'm minded to agree with counsel
Jennings the fact this extends down to
become a French window I I don't think
it's gonna really add to the overlooking
effect it's already there
I don't think I need to defer this the
counselor pairing of course if you want
to make a formal proposal for a
deferment feel free to do so it's up to
you I'm very happy to make a proposal
for deferment I just feel it's very
difficult to make a sound judgment on
overlooking without having actually been
in the property itself and I just want
to be fair to both the objectors and the
applicant okay counts I didn't second
that okay thank you
so yes count subject if we just deal
with the deferment first if that's a no
we'll come back to you if that's okay
depending on whether we need to right so
we've had it proposed to defer all those
in favor please show all those against
deferral three Jen no abstentions
therefore which Erin's casting vote I
would say that we can go to the I would
like to go to the next - I don't think
we need to defer this so that falls
Council Jennings I would like to propose
it granted thank you
do we have a seconder to grant to
prepare to this proposition to grant
councillor Dixon seconding right if
there's no further debate on this
doesn't seem like there's should we go
to the vote proposition is to grant this
application all those in favor for
challenge for those against and in the
abstentions very German thank you
therefore the committee results - grant
application reference 19 / 0 - 3 5 7 /
ful that is the last item on tonight's
agenda so with no urgent business
the meeting is closed at so
fifty-eight thank you very much
everybody good night